NATHAN RUNKLE: So my name
is Nathan Runkle.
I'm the founder and executive
director of Mercy For Animals.
And we are a national, nonprofit
animal protection
organization.
And our mission is to prevent
cruelty to farmed animals, and
promote compassionate food
choices and policies.
So I want to talk for a few
minutes about how I got
involved in animal protection
issues.
This is me in St. Paris, Ohio,
a town of about 2,000 people.
I was born on a farm, come
from a long heritage of
farmers, four generations.
In this photo, my father is, I
think, breaking all sorts of
state and federal laws,
potentially--
child endangerment.
But growing up in this
environment, I always had a
natural affinity and connection
for animals.
I spent much of my childhood
exploring the nearby creeks
and streams and looking
at wildlife.
And it was our dogs and cats
that were the first to teach
me that other creatures share
our needs and our desires,
that they have curiosities,
senses of humor.
And it wasn't something that
I had to study in school.
But from a young age, I
witnessed the contradictory
view that we hold for animals.
I saw that our family cared very
much about the dogs and
cats that we had, but we did
not have the same level of
compassion or empathy or respect
for other animals.
So both of my uncles
were hunters and
trappers and fishermen.
So from a young age, I witnessed
animals being
skinned while they were still
alive, having their heads
ripped off while they
were still alive.
And most people in my social
circle did not afford those
animals much consideration.
And that always felt
wrong to me.
I thought that we could and
should do much better.
There was a local animal
abuse case when I
was 15, so in 1999.
That is what ultimately led to
me founding Mercy For Animals.
And it was at a local high
school, and there was a
teacher there who had an
agricultural class.
And this teacher also
ran a pig farm.
Now, one day he brought to
school a bucket of day-old
piglets to be used in a
dissection project.
Now, these were piglets that
he had tried to kill that
morning on his farm.
But when he arrived to the
school, one of the piglets was
still alive.
A student in the class who also
did part-time work on the
teacher's pig farm took the
piglet by her hind legs and
slammed her head-first into
the ground to try
to kill this piglet.
Now, the piglet didn't die.
Her skull was broken.
She was bleeding out
of her mouth.
She's in horrible distress.
A few of the students who were
appalled by this act of abuse
took the dying piglet, left the
classroom, and took her to
a teacher who was known as
being a vegetarian and
sympathetic to animal cruelty.
That teacher left the school,
went to a local vet office,
and had the piglet euthanized.
Now, following that case,
there were two counts of
animal cruelty that were filed,
one against the student
and one against the teacher.
Now, the case generated a lot
of media attention and
controversy in this small
farm community.
And the pig farming community
rallied behind
the student and teacher.
And they said, we don't want
animal advocates coming into
our town, telling us
how to do our jobs.
The very first day of the trial,
the cruelty charges
were dismissed, because it's
considered standard
agricultural practice to kill
piglets by slamming them
head-first into the ground.
And in Ohio, like at least 30
other states in this country,
if something is considered
standard agricultural
practice, no matter how cruel
it is, it's exempt from
cruelty prosecution.
So that case illustrated to me
that there needed to be a
voice for farm animals in
this community in Ohio.
So since then, Mercy For Animals
has grown to having
over 100,000 members
and supporters.
We have five offices
across the country.
And we work to give a voice to
farmed animals in four main
areas-- through public education
campaigns, through
undercover cruelty
investigations, through
corporate outreach, and legal
advocacy efforts.
All right, so there
you have it.
Now, I want to start out by
talking a bit about animals
and our relationship
to animals and
why we should care.
Now, Dr. Jane Goodall once said,
"we have to understand
we are not the only beings on
this planet with personalities
and minds." Now as I'm sure
many of you are aware, Dr.
Goodall spent about 45 years
in Africa living with and
studying chimpanzees.
She was one of the first
researchers to give her
subjects names as opposed
to numbers.
And she started to observe them
and find out that many of
the traits that we once held so
closely as being unique to
people are in fact not unique
and are very widespread in the
animal community--
things like culture and empathy
and compassion, things
like not only using tools,
but creating tools.
So Dr. Goodall started to tear
down these various boundaries.
And I think looking at
this image really
illustrates it so perfectly.
We know that other animals feel
cold, the cold of this
metal, the heat of the sun, that
they form relationships
and bonds, and that they, too,
deserve our consideration.
Now, anyone who has shared their
homes with dogs or cats
knows this.
We know how excited they are
when we come home, how eager
they are for their walks,
how playful they are.
And this is, again, not
something that we had to study
animal behavior to know.
And the scientific community is
finally starting to catch
up to what so many of us
have known all along.
Just this year, the University
of Cambridge published the
Cambridge Declaration
of Consciousness.
And essentially, this is
the first time that an
international group of prominent
scientists supported
the idea that animals are
conscious and aware to the
same degree that humans are.
Now, this was really
earth-shattering for this to
come out, because they found
that not only do mammals have
consciousness and dogs and cats,
but birds have the same
level of consciousness, and not
only birds, but fish, and
not only fish, but octopus.
So this whole notion, I think,
should give all of us pause to
really think about our treatment
of animals and our
obligation to them, and how we
can include them in our circle
of consideration and ethics.
So what we do at Mercy For
Animals is help people step
back and think about farm
animals as individuals with
needs, and how we can respect
them and do due diligence in
protecting their interests.
So I want to talk a little
bit about who
farmed animals are first.
This is an image of the
wild ancestors of
the modern-day chicken.
Now, most people just think
of chickens and
they think of barnyards.
And Of course, these birds once
lived wild in the jungles
of Southeast Asia.
And they lived in a world
that was very rich
with sound and color.
And they lived in social groups
of about a dozen birds.
And they were very active.
Now, we manipulated these
animals to becoming almost
genetic Frankensteins of
what they once were.
And I'll talk about that
a little bit later.
But we see that, even through
hundreds or thousands of years
of domestication, these animals
still have the same
behaviors, the same desires.
These are egg-laying hens that
live their entire lives in
tiny cages.
And this is a photograph of them
about a month after they
were rescued.
And we see that these birds
still want to perch, roost,
dust-bathe.
They spend the night in trees.
Now, the more that we know about
birds, the more respect
we should have for them.
We all know the term "the
watchful mother hen," and this
is a term that these birds
really have earned.
They will give their lives
to protect their young.
They have a very close bond
with their young.
They actually start to chirp
and communicate with them
while they're still in the
eggs in the last few days
before hatching.
We know that birds can recognize
100 other birds
based on their distinct
facial features.
I think if most of us saw a
group of 100 chickens, we'd
think that they all looked
pretty similar.
But to them, they look as unique
and different as each
of us do in this room to us.
We know that they have
a language that
is unique to them.
We know at least 30 different
calls that they have that are
unique for overhead predators
versus ground predators.
They have a more intimate tone
and inflection that they use
with birds that they consider
to be their friends.
We know that chickens understand
that recently
hidden objects still exist.
They're not rocket science, but
this is beyond the ability
of small human children.
That has led Dr. Bernard Rollin
to state, "contrary to
what one may hear from the
industry, chickens are complex
behaviorally, do quite well in
learning, show a rich social
organization, and have a diverse
repertoire of calls.
Anyone who has kept barnyard
chickens recognizes their
distinct differences in
personality." And of course,
anyone who has spent any time
with chickens knows that there
are some who like the attention
of people, who will
follow you around and peck at
your toes, wanting treats, and
others who would prefer
to be on their own.
Now, the scientific community
is starting to catch up to
this notion.
This is an illustration that
appeared in "The Washington
Post" in 2005, where the
scientific community called
for a remapping of the bird
brain, saying that about 90%
of the over-2,000 terms that
we use in referring to the
structure of a bird
brain is outdated.
It needs to be reevaluated.
So what we see on the right-hand
side of this
illustration is the traditional
view of a bird's brain.
And we see that most of it we
thought was just used for
instinctive behaviors, that
birds were going around and
just acting by instincts, with a
very small amount being used
for cognitive behavior
or learning.
But our new view, which we see
in the middle here, is that
over 75% of the bird's brain is
used for complex cognitive
behavior or learning.
Now, pigs are also
intelligent, sensitive creatures.
Some people say that they're
the fourth-most intelligent
creatures on the face
of the planet.
We know that these animals have
strong bonds that they
also form with their young.
We know that they have
a unique language.
We know of at least 20 different
grunts or oinks that
they make that mean very
distinct things.
And we know that they have
long-term memories.
There was a study done at
Penn State University.
They took a group of pigs
and they presented
them with three objects.
One was a dumbbell, one was a
Frisbee, and one was a ball.
And they taught the pigs to pick
up the Frisbee, to sit
next to the dumbbell, and
to jump over the ball.
And they took those pigs away
for three years, without ever
seeing those objects.
Three years later, they brought
them back, presented
them with the objects, and 100%
of the pigs, without any
retraining or prompting,
remembered those behaviors
that they were taught
three years before.
Now, Dr. Donald Broom said,
"pigs have the cognitive
ability to be sophisticated.
Even more so than dogs and
certainly three-year-olds."
He's talking about
three-year-old humans.
Anyone who has children or
nieces or nephews knows just
how intelligent three-year-olds
are, how they
have a sense of humor
and curiosity.
To think that that same level of
thinking is going on in the
mind of a pig should give
us all pause to
how we treat them.
Now, researchers have taught
pigs how to play video games
using remote-controlled
joysticks, showing that they
understand cause and effect.
Now, I have mixed feelings about
bringing an entire other
species into the video
game revolution.
I think it's causing problems
for our own species.
But nevertheless, there it is.
And then, of course, we have
cows, I think some of the most
benevolent, peaceful creatures
on the planet.
These are animals that,
again, form strong
bonds with their young.
We hear story after story of
mother cows who have been
separated from their young,
not only bellowing out in
distress for days on end, but
jumping over fences and
traveling miles on end to be
relocated with their young.
We know that cows have best
friends that they spend most
of their time with, and that
they show excitement when they
solve problems.
And finally, I want to talk for
just a second about fish.
Now, most people don't give
much thought to fish.
And it's easy to really
disregard them, because they
inhabit a world that
is so different
from us, under water.
They don't have the same ability
to express their
feelings through facial
features.
They can't scream.
But fish are not swimming
vegetables.
And we know that these animals
suffer pain and fear and
distress in much the same
way that we do.
They did a study where they took
fish and they injected
bee venom under their scales.
And what they found is that
the fish's heart rate
elevated, that they started
swimming frantically back and
forth in the enclosure, and
rubbing that area of their
body against the enclosure.
Their brains also release
natural painkillers.
And they release oxytocin, our
natural feel-good drug.
This is an illustration of the
structure of a fish brain
versus a human brain.
What we see is that, though
they may be structured
differently, they still have
the same functions.
So here we see that, on the
surface of the fish's
[INAUDIBLE] brain, there are
structures that serve
functions similar to the limbic
system of mammals.
In mammals, these cerebellar
receptors are responsible,
among other things, for the
emotional evaluation of
information, and they play a
role in creating memories and
the learning processes.
And we know, too, that fish can
use tools, that some of
them form life-long monogamous
relationships with other fish.
And I say all this because
I think we've become so
disconnected from
these animals.
Few of us will ever spend much
time with a cow or a pig or a
chicken, so it's good
to know this.
But I really don't think it
matters all that much if these
animals can solve mathematical
equations, because these are
arbitrary tests that we've
created for other animals
based on our own intelligence.
Jeremy Bentham said, "the
question is not can they
reason nor can they talk, but
can they suffer?" And I think
that we are at a time where
there's really no legitimate
debate now whether animals
can suffer.
They have brains,
central nervous
systems, nerve endings.
Pain to them is used in the same
way as it is for us, as a
way to move away from negative
stimuli to protect them.
So I think the test that we have
as ethical, conscious,
moral creatures is, how can we
live on this planet and do the
most good and the least harm?
And knowing that farm animals
suffer pain, how can we in
good conscience ignore
their plight?
So what is the plight
for these animals?
Well, about 60, 70, 80 years
ago, most farm animals lived
relatively decent lives, outside
in small flocks.
And this is an illustration
showing that.
Many of them were even
slaughtered on the farm.
But unfortunately,
much has changed.
In fact, so few people are
involved in agriculture now,
less than 2%, that they're
removing it from the Census
Bureau occupational section.
So with this change, and the
amount of meat that people are
consuming in this country, we've
seen a huge increase in
the number of animals being
killed for food.
Now over eight billion, with a
B, farmed animals are killed
every year in this country.
This is a graph showing the
slaughter rate of animals.
Nearly 300 chickens are killed
every single second in this
country, over three pigs killed
every second, and a cow
every single second.
Now, these numbers, none
of us can really grasp.
As the saying goes, one death
is a tragedy, but a million
deaths, or in this case eight
billion, is just a statistic.
It's really difficult for us
to relate to these numbers,
they're so mind-boggling.
But it's one, and then one, and
then one, all the way up
to eight billion.
So gone are the days of the
idyllic barnyard scenes that
we grew up with in movies and
our children's books.
And this is what a modern-day
farm looks like.
This is a factory egg farm.
And on this small piece of
property, you can find
millions of animals intensively
confined.
This is what most people know
about our current agricultural
system, nothing.
They're kept completely
in the dark on how
these animals are treated.
And that's because the meat,
dairy, and egg industry spend
millions and millions of
dollars every year
spoon-feeding us ads about happy
cows and happy chickens
to mask the reality of this
institutional and
industrialized farming system.
So what we aim to do at Mercy
For Animals with our
undercover investigations is to
pull back the curtains of
these facilities, and to shine
a bright spotlight on these
animals' plights.
So now in industrial farming, we
see that animals are being
treated as commodities,
resources, machines, and
production units.
This is a quote that appeared
in "National Hog Farmer"
magazine that said, "the
breeding sow should be thought
of and treated as a valuable
piece of machinery whose
function is to pump out baby
pigs like a sausage machine."
And we see that these
intelligent, sensitive
creatures have been reduced
to just that, machines.
They live their lives in tiny
crates where they can't even
turn around or lie down
comfortably for nearly their
entire lives.
They resort to bar-biting,
banging their heads against
the wire and steel structures
of their cages, because
they've literally gone insane.
We've created genetic
Frankensteins chickens.
On the right here, we have the
modern broiler chicken, named
literally after the
cooking method.
These are meat-type birds.
On the left, we have the
modern-day egg-laying chicken.
So what we've done is we've
taken these meat-type birds
and we've bred them to grow so
large so fast that many of
them can't even withstand
their own body
weight on their legs.
Now, back in the 1950s, it
took almost 70 days for a
chicken to reach
market weight.
Today, it takes about 47,
in some cases 35.
They're continuing to chip time
off of these animals'
lives, and they're reaching
a much larger weight.
So we essentially have
our baby animals
in obese adult bodies.
And what we see is that they
suffer from leg disorders,
heart and lung failures, and
they're in chronic pain.
Now, a study found that 90% of
these broiler chickens will
eat feed that's laced with
painkillers to self-medicate
themselves, they're in
such chronic pain.
And the same is true
for turkeys.
This is a photograph taken
at a Butterball
facility in North Carolina.
And this is where the tom
turkeys, or the male turkeys,
are used for breeding.
Some of these turkeys
reach 90 pounds.
They can hardly walk by the time
that they're slaughtered.
Now, egg-laying chickens have
bred to be smaller birds, but
to produce an unnaturally
high amount of eggs.
Now, before we domesticated
these animals, they laid about
24 eggs a year.
In the 1950s, they would lay
about 120 eggs a year.
Today they lay over
200 eggs per year.
This takes an extreme toll
on their bodies.
Their calcium is being used to
produce the eggs, so they
suffer from broken bones
and osteoporosis.
And this is how 95%
of the hens in
this country are confined.
They're kept in cages the size
of a file drawer cabinet, with
anywhere from five
to seven birds.
They can't even spread
their wings.
They can't walk, perch,
roost, dust-bathe.
They can't do anything that
comes natural to them.
And then we have cows that are
used for milk production.
These animals are artificially
inseminated time and time
again, because cows, like all
other mammals, have to give
birth in order to lactate.
So what happens to
these baby cows?
They're taken away.
Many of them go into
the veal industry.
The mothers live like this for
about five years, and then
they're slaughtered.
I think this ad poses the
question rather bluntly.
Do we need to be drinking
cow's milk at all?
We hear the term that milk
is nature's perfect food.
And cow's milk is nature's
perfect food, if you're a baby
calf who's doubling in
size every few weeks.
But when we think about it,
we're the only species to
drink milk past infancy.
We're the only species
to drink the
milk of another species.
And this has led to a system
of just absolute horror and
cruelty for these animals.
Now, Ruth Harrison, in her book
"Animal Machines," said,
"if one person is unkind to an
animal, it's considered to be
cruelty, but where a lot of
people are unkind to animals,
especially in the name of
commerce, the cruelty is
condoned and, once sums of money
are at stake, we defend
it to the last by otherwise
intelligent people."
And I think that this really
puts into perspective our
current view and treatment of
animals in this country.
Polls have been done by Zogby
and Gallup, Ohio State
University, universities across
the country, that find
that Americans oppose
animal abuse.
93% of Americans say animals
deserve protection from
cruelty, neglect, and abuse.
93%.
I challenge you to find any
other issue in this country
where you can get 93%
of people to agree.
But when it comes to
animals, we stand
united in that belief.
But that belief does not reflect
our actual treatment
of the majority of animals.
So I'm going to show a short
four-minute video, and it
shows what happens on factory
farms and slaughter houses.
Some of you may find it a bit
disturbing, but I think to be
ethical consumers, it really
is our obligation to take a
look at these systems.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-In the next few minutes, you
will be given an eye-opening
look behind the closed doors of
modern farms, hatcheries,
and slaughter plants, revealing
the journey that
animals make from
farm to fridge.
Crowded by the thousands into
filthy sheds, chickens and
turkeys are denied many of
their most basic natural
behaviors and needs, such as
fresh air and exercise.
Sick or injured birds often
have their necks broken.
Others are clubbed to death.
At the slaughter plant, the
birds are dumped from their
crates, then roughly snapped
upside down into moving
shackles by their
fragile legs.
From there, the birds are
dragged through an electrified
vat of water which renders
them paralyzed, but not
necessarily unconscious.
They are then pulled across
a blade which slices their
throats, causing blood to
pour from their necks.
The egg industry subjects chicks
to horrors few of us
can even imagine.
Because male chicks don't lay
eggs and do not grow quickly
enough to be raised profitably
for meat, they are killed
within hours after hatching.
Male chicks are typically thrown
into giant grinding
machines while still alive.
Another killing method is to
drop male chicks into trash
bags to be smothered
or suffocated.
The females have it even worse,
destined for a life of
prolonged cruelty.
To reduce packing induced by
overcrowded living conditions,
workers use a hot blade or laser
to remove part of the
chick's beaks.
This mutilation can cause both
acute and chronic pain.
After debeaking, the birds are
moved to cages where they will
spend the rest of their lives.
Nearly 95% of egg-laying hens
spend their lives confined in
tiny wire cages like this.
The majority of today's
dairy cows are
confined on factory farms.
Workers subject young cows to
painful mutilations and
amputations.
Here, a worker cuts off a cow's
tail, slicing through
her sensitive skin, nerves,
and bone without any
painkillers.
Injuries and illness often
run rampant in filthy,
disease-ridden factory
farm environments.
Cows too sick or injured to
stand are called downers, and
are often left to slowly
suffer and
die from their injuries.
Calves on dairy farms are
dragged away from their
mothers and violently killed,
all so that humans can have
the milk instead.
At a fraction of their natural
lifespan, the so-called spent
dairy cows are prodded onto
transport trucks and shipped
to slaughter houses.
-Come on!
-Unreliable stunning practices
at the slaughterhouse condemn
many cattle to having their
throats cut and their limbs
hacked off while still
alive and conscious.
For nearly their entire
four-month pregnancies, mother
sows are locked in narrow metal
stalls barely larger
than their own bodies.
Soon after birth, piglets are
castrated by workers who cut
into their skin and rip
out their testicles.
Next, the workers chop
off their tails.
Both of these painful procedures
are nearly always
done without anesthesia.
The piglets who become sick or
injured people or who are not
growing quickly enough
are killed.
Common killing methods including
being slammed
head-first into the ground.
Once pigs have reached
market weight,
they are sent to slaughter.
At the slaughterhouse, pigs are
knocked in the head with a
steel rod, hung upside down, and
have their throats slit.
Improper stunning condemns
many pigs to having their
throats slit while they are
fully conscious and suffering.
If you are at all moved
by this film,
please do your part.
Make a commitment today to
explore a vegan diet.
For delicious vegan recipes,
nutritional information and
tips on making the transition to
a plant-based diet, please
visit chooseveg.com.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
NATHAN RUNKLE: Now, in his
book "Eating Animals,"
Jonathan Safran Foer spoke to
a number of factory farmers
about these issues.
And many of them wanted
to remain anonymous.
This is a quote from
one of them.
"What I hate is when consumers
act as if farmers want these
things, when it's consumers who
tell farmers what to grow.
They've wanted cheap food.
We've grown it." And I think
when a lot of people see this
video, they're angry.
And a lot of times, they direct
that anger towards the
individual employees in these
facilities instead of stepping
back and looking at the system
in a broader, larger view.
What w found is that, in many
of these factory farm and
slaughterhouse environments,
the workers are victims of
this system in much the same
way as the animals are.
Many of them are undocumented
workers.
They take this work because
it's the only
work they can find.
They work long hours.
And what we see is that many
of them are very troubled
initially by what
they see there.
And in fact, there have been
studies done that find that
many slaughterhouse and factory
farm workers suffer
from what's called
perpetration-induced traumatic
stress disorder, which is
essentially a form of
post-traumatic stress disorder
that comes about when people
are put in situations to do
things that they find morally
unacceptable.
We saw this in some situations
with Nazis and executioners,
people that are in
war environments.
We're seeing the same thing in
factory farm workers and
slaughterhouse workers.
And as a result, we see
increased levels of alcohol
and drug abuse.
We see increased numbers of
domestic violence disputes.
So I think we have to ask
ourselves, if this system is
so unpleasant and violent
and cruel that it causes
psychological distress and
damage to the people that have
to work in them, what does that
say about the practice?
And is that something that we
should be supporting in a
civilized society?
The other thing that people say
is, this footage must be
old, this must be out of the
United States, this couldn't
possibly be happening
in the 21st century.
We have laws and regulations
for everything, right?
Well, unfortunately pretty much
all of this footage that
you saw was taken in the
last five years alone
in the United States.
This is just a snapshot
of the treatment
these animals endure.
So what do the laws look
like in this country?
Well, unfortunately they
don't look very
promising for farmed animals.
We have a system where
agribusiness is so large and
powerful that they've been able
to lobby so that state
and federal laws are written
in a way that
exempt farmed animals.
So on a federal level, we see
that there's not a single
federal law that provides
protection to farmed animals
during their lives
on factory farms.
There is a federal law for
transport and slaughter for
mammals, but it totally exempts
birds, which make up
over 95% of the animals used
for food production.
So for the majority of these
animals' lives, no protection
on the federal level.
The Humane Methods of Slaughter
Act exempt birds,
which means that many of them
have their throats slit and go
into the scalding tanks while
they're still alive.
Now, all 50 states have
anti-cruelty laws, varying in
scope and definition.
But most of them completely
exempt or largely exempt farm
animals from their protection.
So similar to the case that I
described earlier about the
piglet being slammed into the
ground, we see that other
routine practices that cause
extreme suffering for animals
are allowed to happen on
a state level as well.
Things like inflicting
third-degree burns on animals
that are conscious without
painkillers is deemed legal
because of exemptions.
Castrating piglets, legal
without painkillers because of
exemptions.
Now, to put this into context,
if you had a puppy that you
took to your local vet and
said, I'm here to have my
puppy neutered, and your vet
took your puppy by his hind
legs, held him up, took out a
scalpel, cut him open, ripped
out his testicles and hand the
puppy back to you, you
probably wouldn't be very
thrilled or excited with your
vet visit, and you'd probably
call law enforcement, and that
vet would probably be shut
down for malpractice and
charged with animal cruelty.
But we do this to piglets
every single day.
And these aren't even vets
that are doing this.
These are untrained, unskilled
workers working
at an alarming rate.
And then we have things like
cutting the beaks off of
chickens without
any painkillers
also allowed to happen.
So we've handed the power to
decide what is cruelty and
what is acceptable to the very
industries that profit off of
using these animals
themselves.
And it hasn't worked.
Now, the good news is that we're
starting to see some
change on this issue
as consumers
wake up to these practices.
In 2008, California passed
Proposition 2.
And Proposition 2 was a modest
yet meaningful initiative that
said that calves raised for
veal, pregnant pigs, and
egg-laying hens had to be given
enough space to stand
up, turn around, lie down,
and extend their limbs.
Now, that ballot initiative
passed by an
overwhelming majority.
63% of California voters
passed Proposition 2.
More people voted for Prop 2 in
2008 than voted for Obama
in California.
And this law really helped
set a precedent.
Since then, we've had nine
states pass laws banning these
tiny gestation crates for
breeding pigs, a number of
states banning battery cages for
egg-laying hens and veal
crates, also being outlawed.
But there's still much
work to be done.
Now, I want to tell
you a quick story
about this man here.
His name is Virgil Butler.
Virgil Butler worked for almost
10 years in a Tyson
slaughterhouse in Arkansas.
And Virgil's job was to take
birds as they arrived in
crates and snap them into those
moving conveyor belts
that you just saw.
Now, Virgil witnessed a lot of
abuse, not only the standard
mistreatment of these animals,
but he witnessed his
co-workers stomping on birds,
ripping their heads off,
putting ice bombs in them and
watching them explode on the
slaughter line.
And over time, Virgil started
to become very disturbed by
what he saw.
He started having nightmares.
And he said, I can't
be involved in
this system any longer.
So Virgil quit his job.
He had no real financial
backing.
This is his trailer that he
lived in behind him, in this
photograph.
And he went vegan,
and he became an
animal rights activists.
And he started blogging about
what he saw, not only to
expose the abuse, but as
self-therapy as well.
And he started traveling the
country, sharing his firsthand
experiences with others.
So I think that Virgil is one
of many examples of someone
who can be so invested and
involved in this system, but
can still be in touch with that
greater good that he has,
that spark of humanity.
And he has made changes.
And I think that if Virgil can
do this, any of us, no matter
where we are in our current
lives, can make changes, can
take steps to become
more compassionate.
Now, we live in an era where
our forks and knives have
become, really, weapons
of mass destruction.
We can use them for compassion
and kindness for animals, or
cruelty and exploitation.
Now, I think if these were eight
billion dogs or cats
that were being subjected to
these conditions, there would
be such a public outcry.
And we should have that same
level of outcry for farmed
animals as well.
Now, "The Economist" put it
well, I think, when they said,
"few people would keep a hen in
a shoe box for her entire
egg-laying life; but practically
everyone will eat
smartly packaged, 'farm fresh'
eggs from battery hens." Few
of us in good conscience would
treat these animals in the way
that you've seen
this afternoon.
But when we go to the
supermarket and we buy these
products, we're essentially
hiring someone to do this
dirty work on our behalf.
So we have to ask ourselves,
do we feel comfortable
supporting this abuse
financially?
Because that's what we're doing,
is we're financing it.
Now, our food choices
have a huge impact.
The average American eats about
2,700 land animals in
their lifetime.
So by making some dietary
changes, by eliminating meat
on Mondays, or reducing our meat
consumption, becoming a
flexitarian, or becoming a
full-blown vegan, we can help
spare animals this suffering.
And this is an illustration
showing
those number of animals.
And we really are at a
critical juncture.
We're at a time when not only
is animal abuse rampant in
this industry, but the
environmental impact of animal
agriculture is very extreme
and severe.
The United Nations published
a report, "Livestock's Long
Shadow," that found that
animal agriculture is
responsible for the release of
more greenhouse gases than the
entire transportation
sector combined.
18% of greenhouse gases are
associated with the livestock
sector, so more so than cars,
trains, automobiles combined.
So not only are we wreaking
havoc on animals and the
environment, but also to
our own health as well.
And that's what's led the UN
to say that we should be
eating less meat to curb
global warming.
And we see that it's not just
global warming, but it's a
waste of resources.
We have to use so much water,
which is a scarce commodity,
and growing scarcer now
across the globe.
We see that we're funneling so
much grain into animals to get
a relatively small amount
of meat in return.
Now, this is an article that
appeared all over the country
recently, but this particular
screenshot is from Drovers
CattleNetwork.
It's America's best business
source for beef producers.
This is on the homepage
of their website.
It says we will all
be vegetarian by
2050, scientists say.
And this is not because
everyone chooses to be
vegetarian by 2050, but because
we simply will not be
able to sustain meat production
for a growing
population by then.
So we're at a juncture where
we can either choose to be
innovative in solving this
issue, or we can be dragged
there by necessity, by the
collapse of our environment
and ecosystems and animal
cruelty just
being out of control.
Now, thankfully there are some
real pioneers that are jumping
on the plant-based
diet bandwagon.
We have Biz Stone, who I'm sure
all of you have heard of
before, who is a proud vegan,
an ethical vegan.
We have Russell Simmons founder
of Def Jam Records,
who has adopted a plant-based
diet, former President Bill
Clinton, who is an outspoken
advocate for plant-based
eating, and then we have
billionaire Steve Wynn, from
Las Vegas, who is also jumping
on the veggie bandwagon.
It's not just some of the
brightest minds and
entrepreneurs, but we have
sports athletes.
The Houston Texan Arian Foster,
who is a proud vegan
now as well, showing that we
sacrifice nothing, not our
strength, not our health,
by eliminating meat.
We gain everything.
And we're starting to see the
new generation of college
students embracing this idea
and the need as well.
A recent study found that in
the last three years, the
number of vegans on college
campuses has doubled.
The number of vegetarians
increased by 50%.
And there are now all-vegan
dining halls in this country,
including one right here in
Texas at Denton University.
And this is an image of the
Denton vegan dining hall.
Now, "Washington Post" did a
survey that said, what will
future generations
condemn us for?
And they found that second only
to our treatment of the
environment is our treatment of
animals in food production.
So I think that this is a
generational issue, like so
many social issues are.
And this is one of our time.
We have billions of animals that
are being subjected to
horrors beyond belief.
And I think that future
generations will ask us, what
did we do to right this wrong?
I think that animal protection
is a social justice movement.
Based on the number of
individuals that are suffering
and the degree of their
suffering, I think it's one of
the most pressing of our time.
Unlike other social justice
movements, where those that
are being oppressed had a
voice in society to some
degree-- they could protest,
they could lobby, they could
ask for boycotts--
these animals can't do that.
Now, you saw in this video
of factory farms and
slaughterhouses that these
animals kick and scream.
They struggle and fight against
their oppressors to
the best of their ability.
But they do rely on each and
every one of us to speak out
on their behalf within our
society and culture.
We are in a situation where
we hold all of the power.
And these animals are completely
at our mercy.
Now, what we do with that power
is totally up to us.
And with power comes
responsibility.
And as Harriet Beecher Stowe
said, "it's a matter of taking
the side of the weak against the
strong, something the best
people have always done." And I
think it's hard to imagine a
group of individuals that are
weaker and more vulnerable
than farmed animals.
So I encourage you to take the
side of the weak against the
strong, and make decisions and
take actions that will help
bring compassion and
justice to them.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN RUNKLE: I think we have
time for some questions if
anyone has any.
Yeah, so Europe, I would say, is
about 10 years ahead of the
US in terms of addressing farm
animal protection issues.
They, in some cases about 10
years ago, started banning
veal crates, battery cages,
gestation crates.
And some of those are now taking
effect, some of them
last year, some of
them next year.
So yes, they're starting to
address those issues.
Now, we have other countries,
unfortunately, more developing
countries like India, that for
the longest time sort of held
as its root belief that animals
deserved compassion.
Now we're seeing factory farm
interests, McDonald's, Burger
King, Wendy's, coming into
these countries.
And meat consumption is
dramatically rising.
And with that, we see
factory farming
coming into those countries.
So for example, in India,
there's as many hens in
battery cages in India
as there are in the
United States now.
So we see some countries that
are leading the way and ahead
of us, and then we have others
that are actually just sort of
catching up with factory
farming.
So it's an issue that needs
to be addressed globally.
Yeah, I don't know all the
specifics of their other
economics there.
But one issue is, you can look
at grids and you can see just
how meat consumption has
dramatically increased in the
United States.
Now, the good news is, since
2007, meat consumption in the
US has started to decline,
really for the first time.
We're now killing about 400
million fewer farm animals
than we were in 2007.
That's about a 12% decline.
In Latin America, my guess would
be that they're probably
eating more cows than
they are chickens.
And those are animals that you
can have out in a grazing area
more, which costs less than
these intensive factory farm
systems would.
It's a great question.
Sort of like the quote from the
anonymous factory farmer,
it's not that farmers are run by
a bunch of sadistic people.
These are people that respond to
the marketplace and supply
and demand.
So we see the plant-based food
market just dramatically
exploding as people become
more aware of it.
Bill Gates actually--
this is not a joke--
recently said that, really,
the future of food is in
plant-based proteins and
things-- again, looking at the
environmental impact,
the cruelty issues.
So I think we're going to
see more of that grow.
In terms of these cage-free,
free-range, so-called humane
meat products, it's a
business decision.
But ultimately I think it's a
business decision that is
helping animals to
some extent.
They're getting them out of
these really intensive
confinement systems.
But I don't think that the
typical cage-free or
free-range egg facility looks
like what most people think it
should look like, because you're
absolutely right--
they're the same big-interest,
the big factory farms that are
producing these eggs.
And we've done investigations
at these places.
They'll have one shed on the
same property that are battery
cages, and the next shed will
be the cage-free eggs.
And they'll have literally tens
of thousands of birds in
windowless sheds.
They're not in cages, which
is an improvement.
Some of them have perches.
They can walk around, but
they're not frolicking out in
the field like most people
would imagine.
So I think it's progress, but
it's certainly not perfection.
And I think, overall, we need to
at least be decreasing the
amount of animal products
that we're using.
It's about efficiency.
These are factory farms.
They're the model
of efficiency.
And if they can mechanize
everything and have animals in
a smaller area, it takes less
labor to get the job done.
It takes less heating
and electricity to
operate those units .
So it's all about efficiency.
I mean, certainly there's
land available
to give these animals.
I don't think that the world
or life is ever in
black-and-white terms, and
we understand that.
Now, we certainly think that
a vegan diet is, in most
situations, the most ethical,
compassionate, environmentally
friendly choice that
we can make.
So of course we hold that
as the gold standard.
But we understand that there are
gradations along the lines
of agriculture.
We have intensive factory
farm systems, which is
unfortunately how the vast
majority of food is produced.
It's like I said, 95%
of egg-laying hens.
We've got pretty much all
the broiler chickens.
About 80% of pigs are
intensively confined.
This is the gold standard.
These other situations are such,
really, the monopoly
that you have to go out
of your way to find.
So we think people need to know
what the choices are.
But is a cow that's lived out
her entire life in pasture and
then was killed on the farm
better than a factory farm?
Absolutely, it's better.
Do I think that we should be
killing the cow rather than
eating carrots?
Probably the carrots
is a better
choice for me, ethically.
If I don't have to take
a life and be
violent, probably wouldn't.
But there are people that just
don't share that belief.
And I think for them, doing,
again, as little harm and as
much good as possible is really
what we should be
looking at.
And certainly, whether you're
a die-hard meat-eater or a
vegan, we can all probably agree
that this factory farm
system just doesn't fall
into line with what
is ethical for us.
Yeah, it's true.
A lot of these animals still go
to the same slaughterhouse.
Some of them are killed
on the farm.
But again, that's such
a small percentage.
So yes, a lot of them go to
the same slaughterhouses.
For egg-laying hens, most of the
chicks still come from the
same hatcheries.
So all the male chicks are
still ground up alive.
They still have their
beaks cut off.
So there are built-in, I think,
moral issues that we
have to look at with animal
agriculture to begin with.
And those are things that we
have to sort of come to terms
with what we're comfortable
with.
There is an amount of domination
and exploitation
that's involved in any
agricultural system, of course.
So you're absolutely right.
I think it does boil down to,
are we OK with some amount of
violence to animals for food,
or do we just want to remove
ourselves completely
from that system?
I've chosen to remove myself
from that system.
But to say that all farms are
exactly the same I think
probably oversimplifies
the issue a bit.
But those are things that we
should all just be aware of as
conscious consumers, yeah.
Yeah, it's a great question.
And a big part of why meat,
dairy, and egg products are so
cheap is because they're
subsidized by the government.
If we were actually paying the
true cost, those products
would be much higher.
So I think that's a whole issue
that we really need to
take a critical look at.
But there's obviously a vegan
diet that can be very
expensive, that you're
eating a lot of niche
meat-alternative products
that are made.
And then you can have one that
is based more on beans and
nuts and legumes and vegetables
and things that
can, in some situations,
actually be
cheaper to eat that way.
But in terms of addressing this,
there are a number of
companies now-- one
is Beyond Meat--
that is looking to make
meat-alternative products that
are cheaper than meat
products are.
They have no fat, no
cholesterol, high protein,
really being innovative in
addressing these issues.
And then some of it is
supply and demand.
And the more it's a niche
market, the more it's going to
cost to create each unit.
So I think that there's
sort of a number
of answers to that.
But again, I think that
Americans, and just our whole
humanity, really, have proven
time and again that we can be
creative in solving
a lot of problems.
I think Google is a great
example of doing things that
people once thought
were unheard of.
This is an issue where I think
if we put the time and
attention and resources, it can
be solved rather quickly.
And I think we're starting to
see, in some ways, capitalism
and these inventive companies
starting to jump in and
address it as well.
So we have a multi-prong
approach.
Again, these are complicated,
deeply rooted issues.
So to say that there is a
one-size-fit-all answer that's
going to address this in any
sort of timely manner I think
is probably oversimplifying
it a bit.
So that's why we have the four
areas that we work in,
education being a large
component of that.
Getting people to see what's
really going on and
encouraging them to reduce or,
ideally, eliminating their
meat, dairy, egg consumption,
that's really the root cause
of all of this, obviously.
But we understand that the
world is not going to go
vegetarian or vegan, certainly
not overnight.
And we think that these animals
that are here right
now, suffering as individuals
with needs and interests,
deserve to be treated with as
much care as we can give them.
That being said, changes happen
slowly over time.
So we view banning some of the
worst factory farm practices,
like these battery cages for
egg-laying hens, where they
can't spread their wings, or
gestation crates for sows,
where they can't turn around,
or tail-docking, cutting the
tails off these animals without
painkillers, as being
really unethical practices that
we should be moving to
end right now, and that we can
start to reduce the amount of
suffering that these animals
are subjected to, because
these are real animals,
real lives, the stakes
are real for them.
And though giving them a few
more inches of space might not
solve all the problems-- and we
certainly don't think that
that is the case--
we do think that it reduces
the sum total of suffering
that they're subjected to, as we
move towards a reduction in
animal products, and hopefully
more people starting to
eliminate these products.
So multi-prong approach.
And within that, we have
legislative initiatives.
We have corporate outreach
initiatives, looking at
different power-holders and
stakeholders in this, and how
we can affect change
within that.
It's a great question.
A lot of the success that we've
seen, like Proposition
2, which I mentioned before,
are citizen-driven ballot
initiatives.
A lot of the states where
there is a large farming
community, the legislature is
not voluntarily going to push
through any sort of restrictive
measure that would
challenge such a big
industry there.
So they require ballot
initiatives to come in,
because again, consumers are
really on the side of change,
even when big business isn't.
But the problem is is that only
about half the states in
this country allow ballot
initiatives.
And some of the states, like
Iowa, that has the largest egg
production and the largest
pork production in this
country, do not have ballot
initiative processes.
And their legislature is very
much controlled by big ag.
So the pathway to affect
legislative change there
becomes very challenging.
There is a federal
bill right now.
It's regarding egg-laying
hens.
It's not a perfect bill by any
means, but it would set the
first federal standards for
animals on factory farms.
It would increase the amount
of space that hens have in
these cages.
That is really the first federal
bill that has found
its way to Congress for farm
animals in over 30 years.
And the pork and the beef
industries are fighting
desperately against that bill,
because they don't want to see
any sort of precedent
set on it.
So it's challenging, as we
know legislation can be.
There are a number of
states right now--
I think New Jersey is one of
them-- that are considering a
gestation crate ban in
their legislature.
So that's the main one
that comes to mind.
I don't think, unfortunately,
that Texas has anything
currently that's pending
for farm animals.
So that's sort of the
situation with
legislation right now.
Yeah, it's a good question.
We're not against
food production.
Everyone has to eat.
And there are such
thing as tofu
factories that create jobs.
There are things, soy milk
factories that create jobs,
carrot factories that
create jobs.
So this isn't getting rid
of a bunch of jobs.
It's a shift in the economy,
in where those jobs go.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NATHAN RUNKLE: Exactly.
That's exactly right.
By one industry shrinking or
doing away, a lot of times
other industries take their
place that are more
environmentally sound, are more
progressive, are more ethical.
So that's really what
we're looking at.
So we're just looking at a shift
and a humane economy.
Yeah, I think we do the
best that we can.
This isn't a competition
or a purity test.
So we can eliminate
meat, great.
If we can reduce it on Mondays,
Tuesdays, and/or
Wednesdays, great, because we
don't want anyone to feel
overwhelmed.
We don't want people to feel
like either I'm part of the
vegan team or I'm part of the
I'm gonna eat factory farm
products every meal and not
care about the issue team,
because that doesn't solve
anything either.
So I think that's really
the take-home message--
do the best that you can.
Yeah, well, our Texas offices
is in Dallas, so we do a lot
of work in Dallas.
But there are organizations here
that are doing events,
meet-ups, all sorts of things.
I think Compassion
Over Killing has
a coordinator here.
Last year, there was an Austin
vegetarian festival.
I'm not sure if it's happening
again this year.
But Google it.
Yeah, there's certainly
stuff going on.
And Mercy For Animals hopefully
will be doing a lot
more grassroots work in Austin
in the very near future.
Thank you so much
for your time.
I really appreciate it, guys.